في شمال خانيونس وجنوب دير البلح كانت
لافته للنظر مع استمرار العمليات العسكريه
لكى الطرفين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
منطقه ابو هولي باتجاه نحو الشرق من مناطق
شمال القراره حيث كانت تتمركز قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه شارع كيسوفيم بالكامل وهو
الشارع الذي كان عمليا هو مدخل القوات
الاسرائيليه من مستوطنه كيسوفيم ومعسكر
كيسوفيم باتجاه خانيونس المناطق الشماليه
من خانيونس كل هذه المنطقه تم الانسحاب
منها الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وصلت
منطقه ابو هولي عند مصنع المطاحن انسحبت
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه ورصد
الصحفيون اثار الدمار الكبير في شارع صلاح
الدين الممتد من شمال قطاع غزه الى الجنوب
مع تكثيف الغارات الاسرائيليه على هذه
المنطقه اذا هذا انسحاب مهم ولافت للغايه
في عمليه القتال المتواصل في المنطقه
الشماليه من خانو ونحن نتحدث عن حوالي
مسافه تتجاوز حوالي 3 ونص الى 4 م ولكن
السؤال الاهم اين ذهبت هذه القوات التي
انسحبت من منطقه القراره شمال خان يونس
اما انها ذهبت باتجاه الجنوب لتعزيز
الاليات العسكريه والقوات الاسرائيليه
التي تضغط على خانيونس من الجهه الشرقيه
من جهه الزنه بن سهيلا عبسان باتجاه مركز
مدينه خان يونس التي تسعى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى الدخول اليه وتنفيذ عمليات
عسكريه فيه او ان هذه القوات قد تقدمت
اكثر بعد ابو هولي وتقدمت نحو المنطقه
الغربيه والشماليه الغربيه من منطقه مدينه
حمد ومنطقه جوش قطيف والمواصلات على
خانيونس من الجهه الغربيه الاكيد ان
الاليات العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه لخان يونس حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال
الضغط متواصلا القوات الاسرائيليه تتمركز
في اطراف الشرقيه لخان يونس عند منطقه
البلديه تواصل عملياتها من تلك المنطقه
ولكنها حتى هذه اللحظه عاجزه عن توغل داخل
قلب مدينه خانيونس المركز العمليات كما
تقول قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مركز
عمليات المقاومه وكتاب القسام على وجه
التحديد اذا انسحاب من منطقه شمال خانيونس
كان لافتا لنظر خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه ولكن العمليات العسكريه في
المقابل لا تزال متواص في المنطقه
الشماليه ايضا كان هناك انسحابات وشاهدنا
مقاطع فيديو لافته للنظر قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انسحبت من المنطقه من منطقه
الشجاعيه نحو اطراف الشجاعيه انسحبت من
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من اطراف الشيخ
رضوان الى منطقه شمال مخيم الشاطئ تتمركز
في هذه المناطق بعد ان كانت متوغل في كل
هذه المناطق كانت متوغل في تل الهواء
والرمال وصولا الى اطراف الغربيه ل جباليا
انسحبت من هذه المنطقه وتتمركز في
المناطقه الشماليه الغربيه لمخيم الشاطئ
ومنطقه الشيخ ر رضوان شاهدنا مقطع فيديو
خلال اليوم لكتاب القسام قالت انه تم خلال
نهايه الشهر الماضي ا نتحدث عن حوالي اقل
من اسبوعين لتفجير نفق في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان هذا يعني ان العمليات العسكريه او
الكمائن او المقاومه الفلسطينيه من مسافه
الصفر لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت
عنيفه للغايه مقارنه با او استنادا
للفيديو الذي شاهدناه ما دفع الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه للانسحاب شاهدنا
ايضا مقطع فيديو من منطقه الزيتون في
منطقه الزيتون جنوب مدينه غزه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عند شارع ثمانيه تقطع
بهذا الاتجاه تتمركز في هذه المناطق وتدور
في هذه المناطق عمليات عسكريه من المسافه
الصفر بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه التي لا تزال قادره
رغم الضربات الكبيره على الضرب بقوه في
هذه المنطقه وتحديدا المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه ومنطقه خان يونس ومحيطها رغم
الضمار الكبير الذي احدثته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال الاسابيع القليله الماضي